>>Daniel Goleman: There
are three kinds of focus.
One is inner focus, being aware
of our thoughts, of our feelings.
This is the basis for being
able to manage our inner world.
For a child, this is
extremely important.
It's called cognitive control.
Cognitive control means that you can
see when you're about to do something
that maybe you shouldn't and
stop before you do it, not after.
In a landmark study of more than
1,000 children who were followed
from age four into their 30s,
cognitive control was
a better predictor
of a child's financial
success and health in their 30s
than was either their IQ or the
wealth of the family they grew up in.
The second kind of focus is empathy.
It's an other focus.
It's focusing on that other person
and understanding their inner world,
their thoughts, their feelings.
The third is an outer focus.
Being able to sense and understand
the larger systems that impact
and shape our lives, whether it's
the dynamics in an organization,
whether it's a school or a
business or larger systems
like the global systems that
support life and how human activity,
how our choices of what
we buy and do can help
or harm those larger systems.